hey guys dr. Berg here in this short video we're
going to talk about why people eliminate less by
eating more fiber you've heard it people say you
need to eat more fiber and it's going to help you
eliminate but a lot of times it doesn't work
so let's talk about why that is so this whole
idea of fiber creating bulk absorbing water to
make you eliminate more you realize that the
people with chronic constipation consume the
same amount of fiber as people who don't have
constipation yeah so that's interesting people
with chronic constipation get more constipated
when they add more fiber there's a there's also
a small amount of clients that I have where I put
them on seven to ten cups of vegetables and they
get completely constipated so there are certain
people that just don't have the microbes to
digest all that fiber well first thing you
need to know is that you want to consume your
fiber from vegetables and possibly even fruit
if you're not trying to lose weight okay now
let's say you're really constipated and you do
have a weight problem and you've tried everything
well I'm okay with you doing fruit because there
are certain types of fibers in the fruit that
do create elimination like prunes for example
so I have no problem with that because it's
much more important to eliminate than to be
constipated especially if you're trying to lose
weight okay but here's the thing if you consume
all your fiber from fruit and by the way the
recommended amount of fiber that even the USDA
is recommending is 35 grams of fiber per day if
you do that from fruit that's 143 grams of sugar
that's 10 teaspoons of sugar every single day
well that's actually probably even better than
the average American who consumes 31 teaspoons
of sugar every single day but still that's way
too much sugar so you don't want to do all route
you want to do mainly vegetable in fact try not
to do any fruit if you don't have to but vegetable
is the best fiber now I consume at least probably
10 to 15 cups of vegetables a day but I've been
doing it for a long time so my system can process
these fibers so you might want to start off
small and gradually increase but if you below
especially kale then you better back off and try
something else because it's way more important to
not bloat then to consume kale okay and the other
thing is that if you're drinking a lot of water
if you're drinking too much water which by the
way will dehydrate your stool and the reason for
that is that plain water will flush out sometimes
potassium and other electrolytes that you need to
actually hydrate the colon so I have people that
are constipated and they had really Drive stool
and they're drinking like a gallon of water a day
so we cut that back put some electrolytes in and
bam they're actually eliminating one of the most
important minerals for called peristalsis which
is the pumping action of the colon is potassium
so potassium is important especially if you want
to get it from a less n type of electrolyte powder
that will also help you as well because that will
also stimulate part of the nervous system that
helps release this waste materials called the
parasympathetic nervous system and that actually
is kind of the opposite of the sympathetic or the
flooded fight and that's why it you have to be
really stress free and relaxed to eliminate when
you're stressed out there's a reflex that just
turns off the digestive system so anyway I want to
make a point in fiber so go ahead and apply this
information and I will see you in the next video